celle ci auger chantal hébert alec
castonguay bonsoir quand on voit sur
notre téléphone vers 21h 21h15 heure à
remaniement de m commente jean qui
s'applique ça fait monter l'adrénaline
comme impose à ce qu'on secoue monsieur
trudeau vraiment est en train de mettre
la table pour une élection voici ce
qu'il a répondu
non pas du tout on a besoin d'avoir à la
meilleure équipe possible pour continuer
à livrer pour les canadiens pendant
cette crise sans précédent c'est ça
notre focus
voilà alors chantal hébert d'abord on va
dire au revoir a plu aux gens qui
n'étaient pas avec nous mais françois
philippe champagne qui prend la place de
neuve deep bayne qui s'en va les
l'industrie françois philippe champagne
donc prendre la place de monsieur ben
comment marc garneau qui savent aux
affaires étrangères et omar el ghar el
ghabra qui vient du même coin de bain
d'ailleurs mississauga qui prend le
ministère des transports important
ministère des transports chantal hébert
est ce que tout ça être aussi simple que
monsieur ben vous voulez partir tout de
suite puis fallait agir non puisqu'il
voulait pas partir tout de suite mais
néanmoins quand on veut pas faire la
guerre il faut toujours se préparer pour
la guerre alors ce serait imprudent d'en
tirer une conclusion qui voudrait qu'on
le plus tôt possible ce serait imprudent
de la part des partis d'opposition de
tirer la conclusion qui aura pas deux
campagnes électorales parce que monsieur
trudeau dit que c'est parce qu'il veut
dans les faits la décision de m
peines de se consacrer davantage à sa
famille c'est une une excuse qu'on
entend souvent que je crois que dans ce
cas ci qui est sérieuse mais qui veut
pas dire que disparaît de l'horizon
libéral et pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas monsieur benz est à la fois où était
à la fois un ministre à ses solides mais
d'autre part un stratège à ses fins qui
dès la première heure d'appuyer justin
trudeau et qui pourrait trouver à temps
perdu entre deux lectures à ses enfants
du temps pour commencer à planifier la
prochaine campagne électorale fédérale
tout en permettant justin trudeau de
faire des changements qui dans
l'ensemble le servir est assez bien en
campagne électorale
michel ses fonctions philippe champagne
ministre et une novation chant
d'industrie c'est un ministère beaucoup
plus présent pour les canadiens vous
sera moi un voyage chez moi 7 -
comment ces plus petits et moins précis
je vois là merci à michel cherchaient
mais c'est très concret c'est un gros
ministère
deux ministres du québec il y aura un
monsieur garneau qui aura donc le
mystère des affaires étrangères 2010 du
québec
quand même en bonne posture oui et
n'oubliez pas qu'il ya un autre ministre
du québec madame jeudi qui est un
portefeuille économique
alors qu'est ce que c'est nous dit ça
nous dit qu entre autres je suis traîné
non pas du tout mis une croix sur le
québec loin de là sa majorité il peut la
reprendre au québec et monsieur
champagne qui est un bon politicien de
terrain qui est qui pour distribuer les
chèques qu'ils pouvaient aller parler de
vous le gouvernement fait pour vous et
quand même un vendeur assez remarquable
il va être beaucoup plus utile à
l'équipe électorale la queue il l'aurait
été aux affaires étrangères
d'autre part c'est quand même
prestigieux que ça reste un québécois si
monsieur garneau qui veulent la voir et
pour certains dossiers comme par exemple
l'industrie de l'aéronautique et de
l'aérospatial dans la région de montréal
je suis chanteuse être un petit peu plus
joueur à regarder l'aide dont ils ont
besoin que monsieur garneau de l'était
alors puis tout ce qu aucun gouvernement
à faire ce moment ci de l'avis de
gouvernement minoritaire peut être vu
comme électorale alors c'est bien sûr
que les jeunes voient comme so easy way
alec on sait qu'en politique loin des
yeux loin du coeur et ont trouvé que
françois philippe champagne était peut
être très utile aux affaires étrangères
mais qui était peut-être un peu loin
notamment de la bataille à ces critiques
en région au québec qui va se faire
entre le bloc québécois le parti
conservateur et le parti libéral il est
en mauricie françois philippe champagne
c'est une ancienne circonscription de
jean chrétien là c'est un coin qui vont
être chaudement disputés puis c'est
probablement plus utile de l'avoir ici
comme mes collègues l'ont dit que de la
voir aux affaires étrangères encore qu
ils voyagent pas de taxes en pleine
pandémie mais c'est pas des dossiers
bonne nouvelle ce n'est pas d'aider
aussi près des gens alors que
l'instar de l'industrie consomme pour
être un peu plus sexy l'innovation et
science est certainement plus plus utile
à la poche de campagne électorale alors
que marc garneau dangereusement de ville
marie au centre ville pas beaucoup de
concurrence du bloc québécois et du
parti conservateur c'est pas une
circonscription est sans danger puisse
dire est que la réflexion autour dormeur
alga bras et probablement semblables
n'habite baines a emmené très large dans
mississauga melli banlieue de toronto au
grand meeting mississauga c'est très
important pour la prochaine campagne
électorale
avoir un ministre monsieur guillaume
roth qui viennent mississauga qui est un
proche de justin trudeau comme l'était
n'habite baines ça aussi c'est un
message qu'on envoie banlieue de toronto
qui sont encore très importantes pour
moi il ya braille voir des gros dossiers
ministère des transports il ya des gros
gros dos si chantal demain matin sur sa
table demain matin mais je pense qu'il
faut aussi s'entendre sur le fait qu'on
avait convenu qu entre marc garneau le
minus précédent et l'industrie aérienne
et en particulier les compagnies
aériennes le dialogue passe est de moins
en moins on se battait davantage sur la
sphère publique contre que d'autres
façons alors l'idée de mettre un nouvel
interlocuteur
ça pourrait permettre au gouvernement et
aux compagnies aériennes de reculer dans
les ports et essayer d'harmoniser un peu
ce qu'on peut le début de la pandémie
entre temps monsieur garneau ministre
des affaires étrangères certainement qui
a la pointure pour l'emploi mais c'est
aussi un signal que par exemple sur le
front des relations canado américaines
ont peu baissé un peu la garde à partir
de la semaine prochaine avec une
nouvelle administration davantage par
l'abe
donc ça devient front qui est quand même
moins chose françois philippe champagne
selon moi au sein du cabinet au québec
c'est le meilleur comme une cathode du
gouvernement bon un mot sur garneau plus
généralement quand il al hilal à plumes
chez sujet là la pleine confiance du
patron ça se voit oui elle a pleine
confiance du pétrole parce qu'il est on
peut discuter par exemple chantal disait
que les compagnies aériennes beaucoup de
friture sur la ligne cff
mais échappe pas le ballon alors que
l'on peut dire il ya pour régler le
dossier
mais ils échappent pas le ballon alors
d'adam bruins affaires étrangères pour
une ministre d'habitude est très bien
entouré mais dire ça va être ça va deux
minutes tout à fait respectable il
connaît les états unis ont vécu aux
idéologies disait ce matin des enfants
sont nés aux états unis alors comme il
faut rétablir un certain nombre de
points avec pas mal moins difficile
qu'avec le monsieur qui trompe jamais
mais ça vaut il y est fait capable de
faire
en conclusion on met les choses en ordre
si jamais on devait tomber on voulait
tomber un peu plus tôt parce que là on
est on a le conseil des ministres voulu
pour partir en guerre gens tels qu'on
vous dit en tout cas comme remaniement
du mois de janvier c'est probablement
remaniement plus payant électoralement
dernier remaniement n'avait pas les
boules celui où on avait envoyé la
ministre d'ailleurs et tout ce qui a
suivi celui ci c'est un remaniement qui
de façon générale exposé par le
gouvernement a beaucoup de risques est
probable est que êtes vous d'accord avec
ce qu est ce qu a dit michel c'est tout
à l'heure et que ça montre aussi que le
québec sera aux yeux des libéraux un
terrain extrêmement important ils ont
pas lancé la serviette loin de là
non pas du tout puis effectivement à
michel avait raison quand il dit on a
quand même avec mélanie joly au tourisme
au développement économique et régional
ça aussi c'était un portefeuille à bonne
nouvelle on ajoute françois philippe
champagne qui va être le porte parole du
budget de la relance économique faut pas
oublier que lors du prochain budget on
va annoncer quand même entre 70 et 100
milliards de nouvelles dépenses
devraient donc deux porte parole
francophone québécois capables d'amener
sont un peu partout au québec
l'eau où on va avoir effectivement comme
c'est souvent le cas le québec l'ontario
et formation qui va décider de la
couleur du gouvernement et de sa
majorité alors d'avoir des portefeuilles
économiques dans tes mains des québécois
deux à la fois ça c'est quand même pas
si courant alors oui certainement
quelque chose là-dedans de qui viennent
la réflexion de la prochaine bataille
électorale
et ça prépare peut-être éventuellement
une bataille pour la succession
monsieur champagne et madame fruits
l'amt qui pourrait s'annoncer tout à
fait intéressant oui parce que monsieur
champagne il fait pas de cachette choses
là encore mais au nom de broyer demain
qu'il a serrés dans sa vie si ça se
traduit en votes ça va bien aller pour
l'envers ça c'est c'est de la science
fiction c'est très loin et revenons à
plutôt parce que pour aller en campagne
qu'ils soient des faits auxquels lui
s'arrange pour être défait ça serait
bien que la grande opération vaccination
soit plus avancé on va écouter monsieur
trudeau là dessus qu'ils parlaient de 20
million de nouvelles doses on écoute je
peux aussi annoncé que nous avons conclu
une entente avec pfizer pour accélérer
la livraison des doses de leurs vaccins
d'ici la mi printemps entre avril et
juin nous aurons assez de doses pour
vacciner jusqu'à 20 millions de
personnes
avec cette nouvelle on se rapproche
encore plus de notre objectif qui est
d'offrir des vaccins à tous les
canadiens d'ici l'automne et le comité
je le rappelle pour ceux qui n'étaient
pas avec nous plutôt à l'émission le
comité consultatif a dit oui c'est bien
utiliser la deuxième dose tout de suite
et on pourra atteindre jusqu'à six
semaines pour donner la deuxième demie
châssis roger si cette grande opération
qui permettra de respirer un peu mieux
l'on le on l'espère si ça fonctionne et
si les vaccins arrivent à temps le
problème c'est pas d'acheter les vaccins
soda
on avait déjà suffisamment de toute
manière la question c'est quand est-ce
qu'ils vont se retrouver d'une part
entre les mains du gouvernement fédéral
et donc leur d'autre part entre les
mains des gouvernements profession qui
eux
thaksin et après ça ben est ce que les
provinces vont suivre le rythme
d'acceptation des vaccins et vont être
capables de les distribuer rapidement ce
qui est important c'est à la fin qu'il
ya des citoyens
et quel vaccin comme on dit c'est pas
c'est pas de faire des achats dh on a
fait énormément il n'y allait pas
manquer à la fin c'est le temps oui
c'est le temps et là les 20 millions de
doses supplémentaires
c'est mars avril mais là c'est pas tout
de suite ne sait pas tout de suite
chantal ouais mais c'est quand même une
bonne nouvelle un porte voix qui amène
plus de vaccins plus vite c'est une
bonne nouvelle la possibilit
politiquement que de façon générale pour
la majorité des canadiens
j'ai l'impression mois qu'au fil de la
pandémie le gouvernement justin trudeau
s'est rendu à une réalité c'est à dire
que la place de continuer à promettre
beaucoup qui a livré peu il fait un peu
le contraire alors vous avez entendu
aujourd'hui monsieur trudeau annoncé 20
millions de plus qui arriverait au début
du printemps mais ne pas changer son
objectif de la fin septembre et selon
moi ça s'inscrit dans cette nouvelle
stratégie qu'il l'a assez bien payé
d'ailleurs quatre l'opposition commencé
qui aurait pas assez de vaccins de s'en
tenir à lacets minimale parce qu'ils
viennent de découvrir ça leur a pris du
temps bonne série que j'aime mieux
dépasser les autres de créer des
attentes on peut jamais c'est ce que
j'allais vous dire ça après c'est une
épiphanie pour monsieur et le double ce
chrétien était maître la date baisser
les attentes et de livrer davantage alec
c'est intéressant parce que ce que
chantal dit là on ajoute un million
change pas l'objectif alors on se garde
dans la poche arrière des bonnes
nouvelles
ouais moi j'irais même plus loin on
dirait qu'on vient de se rendre compte
que depuis 2015 on promet beaucoup plus
on lève pas beaucoup les voisins solide
justin trudeau sur vous
on allait révolutionner le ce que le
gouvernement allait faire c'était le
canada est de retour sur la scène
internationale aura quand même échappé
le siège au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
comme les conservateurs avant eux donc
mais c'est vrai que c'est une bonne
stratégie et en décembre l'opposition
ont été déculotté ottawa lorsqu'on est
arrivé avec les bonnes nouvelles
plus de vaccins plus rapidement la
semaine d'avant hier une auto disant on
va être le dernier pays vacciner au
monde ce qui était nettement exagéré
mais c'est certain que cette fois les ça
a vraiment surpris les partis
d'opposition et le cette fois ci c'est
quoi on a eu un accrochage avec les
provinces qui disons labrune plus de
doses plus vite
justin trudeau trouver un peu plus
rapidement évidemment pas d'ici le mois
de mars c'est compliqué tous les pays en
veulent mais si au printemps on peut
avoir vacciné la moitié de la population
canadienne donc on est largement passé
les gros vulnérables ont commencé à
vacciner de manière massive mais là ça
nous change quoi les tic de poids du
politique c'est beaucoup plus facile
ensuite un petit mot chf attendu
aujourd'hui en ontario des annonces
importantes proportionnellement et
encore moins de deux cop père capital
par rapport au québec par exemple mais
la situation s'empire en ontario et là
on a changé le ton du message il ya des
nouvelles mesures adoptées aujourd'hui
on écoute phone systems inc
intéressée à me chasser auger parce que
là on a étendu des mesures si c'est pas
ça dépend un couvre-feu à proprement
parler mais on dit aux gens dressait la
maison sauf sauf si c'est vraiment
nécessaire de sortir
donc c'est quoi finalement comme celui
qu'on a connu au printemps ce qu'ils
lisent des problématiques parce que les
légendes par l'ontario c'est la
compréhension de la population savait le
québec dit à couvre-feu les portes
prochainement total on va laisser des
choses ouverte à nantes à rioz ses
besoins d'un couvre-feu mais par contre
ce théâtre romain confinement et il faut
que la santé publique de la province
explique pourquoi ils font ça pour quoi
ils sont différents des autres aussi
parce qu'elles vont amener les gens sont
mélangés et et de bonne foi les voit que
le québec et l'ontario qui pourchasse
paofai trop disent tous la même chose ça
ça peut être le problème à terme pour
des propos des gouvernements il faut
qu'ils expliquent chantal où on fait la
même chose perdre l'appel pas du même
nom rester chez soi à condition de pas
s'en aller refermer si passionnée dans
un magazine compris chez eux qu'ils
vendront pas des choses essentielles
mais qui devront fermer à 8h au et pas
ouvrir avant 7 heures du matin au
changement les marches de santé j'ai
essayé de voir si je vivais en ontario
ce qui serait très différent de ce qui
arrive au québec pas clair pour les
écoles
oui les écoles sont encore fermés en
ontario et dans certaines régions vont
le rester
y compris aux primaires plus longtemps
qu'au québec mais sur le fond avec des
mots différents arriver assure gens me
demandent aux art assure sans alex
assure sens et ça montre surtout que on
a souvent posé ici au québec mais un peu
partout dans le monde le gouvernement et
les experts la santé publique en réalité
la santé publique c'est pas un bloc
homogène il ya plusieurs avis différent
au sein des spécialistes de santé
publique
ils veulent tous se rendre au même
résultat mais on plusieurs chemins pour
s'y rendre à un endroit on ferme les
écoles à l'autre non un endroit on
apprécie un couvre-feu en ontario on
n'aime pas le terme mais c'est pas très
loin d'un couvre-feu à longueur de
journée avec n'ont peut-être quelques
différences mais ça se ressemble quand
même mais en réalité c'est que plus
stratégiques différents mets donc le
goût les gouvernements celui de
l'ontario celui du québec doivent
écouter leur santé publique et
finalement tranché sur quelque chose qui
n'est pas toujours unanimes en termes de
recommandations puis là on le voit dans
deux provinces pourtant assez similaire
c'est ces frappes a notamment pour les
écoles
c'est là qui est quand même la ligue et
de la différence la plus marquée oui
très bien merci beaucoup de nous avoir
éclairé sur tout ça on se retrouve très
bientôt merci bonne soirée au board